Shure:  记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that song?
Jake: 那个金币是买的对吧
Jake: That coin was bought, right?
Jake: 嗯嗯金币就是买的贴纸
Jake: Yeah, the coin was bought, it's a sticker.
Katrina: 嗯嗯金币就是买的那个贴纸
Katrina: Yeah, the coin was bought, it's a sticker.
Katrina: 对今天应该到了
Katrina: Yes, it should arrive today.
Jake: 那我到了OK哦
Jake: Then it's OK when it arrives.
Shure:  一说到贴纸
Shure: Speaking of stickers...
Shure:  我还有点伴手礼
Shure: I have some small gifts too.
Katrina: 什么叫扳手
Katrina: What do you mean by small gifts?
Jake: 当伴郎去了
Jake: Went to be the best man.
Shure:  什么哈哈
Shure: What, haha?
Shure:  什么烂梗啊
Shure: What a lame joke.
Jake: 不是啊伴手礼不是这玩意吗
Jake: No, isn't a small gift this thing?
Katrina: 啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure: 送你啊
Shure: I'm giving it to you!
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Shure:  这是我们乐队LOGO的贴纸
Shure: It's a sticker with our band's logo.
Katrina: 哇你们你们好正规啊
Katrina: Wow, you guys are so professional!
Shure:  哇周边产品
Shure: Wow, merchandise products!
Lucia: 你们这个贴纸好客系啊
Lucia: Your sticker is so customer-friendly.
Shure:  是的这LOGO花3,000块钱设计的
Shure: Yeah, the logo design cost 3,000 bucks.
Katrina: 3,000 这叫
Katrina: 3,000, that's...
Shure:  送的送的都送了
Shure: Gave it all away.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Wow.
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Shure:  百鸟辞典
Shure: Bird Dictionary.
Shure:  这个大概也符合这个元素我感觉
Shure: I think it fits the theme too.
Jake: 百鸟辞典
Jake: Bird Dictionary?
Jake: 为什么呀
Jake: Why?
Jake: 他怎么3
Jake: Why is it...
Jake: 这这3,000块钱给你什么解释的吗
Jake: Did they give you any explanation for the 3,000 bucks?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  没有我感觉让GPT升升也差不多
Shure: No, I think even GPT could do it similarly.
Jake: 不是他他为什么
Jake: No, why...
Jake: 你给我讲讲呗
Jake: Explain it to me.
Jake: 这为什么长这样啊
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Shure:  就是哎呀
Shure: It's just, uh...
Shure:  我我也不会讲
Shure: I don't know how to say it either.
Jake: 哈哈哈他也没给你讲是吧
Jake: Hahaha, he didn't tell you either, huh?
Shure:  对我这东西真的只可意会不可言传
Shure: Yeah, this is something you just have to feel, can't really explain it.
Shure:  看反了看反了
Shure: You're looking at it backwards, it's backwards.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 雨轩我查了一下如果这样但是
Lucia: Yuxuan, I checked and if it's like this, but...
Lucia: 如果这个花就是有这个花屁股的话
Lucia: If this flower has this kind of base...
Lucia: 对不起戳到了
Lucia: Sorry, bumped into you.
Lucia: 就是花瓣的那个压力就不够
Lucia: The pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 因为他这个
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 我就会把那个压的东西托起来一点
Lucia: I would lift the thing pressing down on it a bit.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 所以就花瓣就是皱的
Lucia: So the petals are wrinkled.
Jake: 那我觉得GPT应该能给你画出来
Jake: I think GPT could draw it for you.
Lucia: 垫一个厚纸巾或者是之类的
Lucia: Put a thick napkin or something under it.
Katrina: 在什么翘屁股的花下面垫一张厚纸巾
Katrina: Put a thick napkin under the flower with the raised base.
Katrina: 因为花托有一定厚度
Katrina: Because the base has some thickness.
Lucia: 可能就是施加到花瓣上的压力不够
Lucia: It might be that the pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 所以他就水
Lucia: So it...
Lucia: 就是一脱水他自己就慢慢缩起来
Lucia: When it dehydrates, it shrinks on its own.
Katrina: 就是单独在他这下面再垫个东西
Katrina: Just put something under it separately.
Lucia: 对就让他跟中间的这个厚度一样
Lucia: Yeah, make it the same thickness as the middle part.
Lucia: 或者就像你说的把花瓣撕下来
Lucia: Or like you said, tear off the petals.
Lucia: 然后但是那样的话
Lucia: But if we do that...
Lucia: 我们是不是到时候要给他自己粘起来
Lucia: We might have to stick them back together ourselves.
Katrina: 那样的话就得自己拼成一个花的形状
Katrina: Then we'd have to piece it together into a flower shape ourselves.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Sigh.
Lucia: 麻烦啊
Lucia: Such a hassle.
Katrina: 对啊我看他们
Katrina: Yeah, I see them...
Katrina: 怎么就
Katrina: Somehow...
Katrina: 直接能压成成一个花瓣的样子
Katrina: They can directly press it into a petal shape.
Katrina: 他们人呢其他的
Katrina: Where are the others?
Lucia: 嗯可心刚才在外面
Lucia: Hmm, Kexin was outside just now.
Lucia: 然后微微我也不知道
Lucia: And Tasha, I'm not sure.
Lucia: 在楼上吗
Lucia: Is she upstairs?
Katrina: 我试一下啊
Katrina: Let me try this.
Katrina: 这桌子好脏啊
Katrina: This table is so dirty.
Katrina: 我先这样试试
Katrina: Let me try it this way first.
Lucia: 好香啊这个咖啡
Lucia: This coffee smells so good.
Lucia: 偷偷喝一口
Lucia: Sneak a sip.
Lucia: 哎算了哈哈哈没事
Lucia: Ah, forget it, hahaha, it's okay.
Katrina: 你喝没事
Katrina: You can drink, it's fine.
Lucia: 是你的吗啊这个咖啡
Lucia: Is this your coffee?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 是我的你喝一口呗
Katrina: It's mine, you can take a sip.
Katrina: 可以哎那边有那个热水应该还烫呢
Katrina: You can, there's hot water over there, it should still be hot.
Katrina: 你可以自己泡一条也行
Katrina: You can make your own as well.
Lucia: 我泡一整杯可能喝不完
Lucia: If I make a whole cup, I might not finish it.
Katrina: 啊没事
Katrina: It's okay.
Katrina: 你倒吧
Katrina: You pour it.
Katrina: 确实很干
Katrina: It really is dry.
Katrina: 但是干的有点
Katrina: But it's a bit too dry.
Shure:  我怀念的
Shure: What I miss.
Katrina: 放歌DJ
Katrina: Play the song, DJ.
Shure:  是无话可说
Shure: There's nothing left to say.
Katrina: 我现在我现在可是正
Katrina: Right now, right now, I'm a positive energy influencer during the day.
Katrina: 能量博主白天啊
Katrina: During the day and at night, I'm like two different people.
Katrina: 白天跟晚上两个人
Katrina: Oh, my head hurts.
Katrina: 哎呦头疼
Katrina: Let me try it first.
Katrina: 我先来试验一下吧
Katrina: The main thing is, this flower is quite big.
Katrina: 主要买这个花都比较大
Katrina: They seem to be more suitable for pressing small flowers.
Katrina: 他们好像比较适合压那种小花
Lucia: 咱的那个
Lucia: Our scissors...
Lucia: 剪刀又上哪了
Lucia: Where did the scissors go?
Shure:  咱们东西
Shure: Our stuff...
Katrina: 今天还用点中饭
Katrina: We had lunch today.
Katrina: 我感觉好饱
Katrina: I feel so full.
Lucia: 今天一会吧
Lucia: Maybe later today.
Lucia: 刚是说什么吃饺子
Lucia: We just said we'd have dumplings.
Shure:  今天是个节气
Shure: Today is a special day.
Shure:  所以不知道吃什么就吃点饺子吧
Shure: So if we don't know what to eat, we can have some dumplings.
Katrina: 行啊给杨老板省钱呢
Katrina: Sure, saving money for Jake.
Katrina: (歌词)我该相信你还爱我吗嗯嗯
Katrina: (Lyrics) Should I believe you still love me, hmm hmm
Katrina: 还是应该明白你
Katrina: Or should I understand you...
Katrina: （歌词）我不再是你I
Katrina: (Lyrics) I'm no longer your...
Katrina: （歌词）可是为什么却苦笑说我都懂了
Katrina: (Lyrics) But why do I pretend to smile bitterly and say I understand everything
Katrina: （歌词）自尊常常将人拖着把爱都走曲折
Katrina: (Lyrics) Pride often drags people along, making love twist and turn
Katrina: （歌词）假装强忍不想太赤裸裸可是覆水难收
Katrina: (Lyrics) Pretending to be strong, not wanting to be too exposed, but it's hard to recover what's lost
Katrina: 话
Katrina: Words...
Katrina: （歌词）不说争吵以后还是想要
Katrina: (Lyrics) Even after the argument, I still want to...
Shure:  他到了吗快递啊快递到了吗
Shure: Has it arrived? The package, has the package arrived?
Katrina: 啊快递到了吗
Katrina: Ah, has the package arrived?
Katrina: 我的快递还没到
Katrina: My package hasn't arrived yet.
Katrina: 什么呢
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 集中在明天
Katrina: All concentrated on tomorrow.
Katrina: （歌词）那片森林
Katrina: (lyrics) That forest.
Jake: 刚刚我在楼上以为下面你们谁在唱
Jake: Just now, I was upstairs and thought someone down here was singing.
Jake: 这个唱挺好
Jake: This singing is quite good.
Shure:  哦我们还可以KTV耶
Shure: Oh, we can even do KTV.
Alice: 嗯你有特别好的朋友吗
Alice: Hmm, do you have any really good friends?
Katrina: 你这个恰鸡皮心口音真异
Katrina: Your accent is really different.
Katrina: 异人能听出
Katrina: Even a stranger can tell.
Jake: 我这恰比比啥了
Jake: What am I even saying?
Katrina: 好像我教导主任了
Katrina: Sounds like my headmaster.
Jake: 哈哈这么这么带范
Jake: Haha, with such style.
Katrina: 教导主任就这口音
Katrina: The headmaster has this accent.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: （歌词） 我的难过比失去难受
Katrina: (lyrics) My sadness is worse than losing.
Katrina: （歌词）我怀念的是无话不说
Katrina: (lyrics) I miss those times when we talked about everything.
Katrina: （歌词）我怀念的是争吵以后
Katrina: (lyrics) I miss the fights we had.
Katrina: （歌词）还是想要爱你的冲动
Katrina: (lyrics) Still wanting to love you after the arguments.
Jake: 是豆腐心菜
Jake: It's tofu heart and vegetable.
Shure:  我感觉是胡诌
Shure: I feel like it's nonsense.
Jake: 这玩意还得上百度
Jake: You need to look this up on Baidu.
Jake: 确实哈哈哈
Jake: Indeed, haha.
Shure:  真的是百度才能要
Shure: Only Baidu can answer this.
Shure:  不问闻心意言吧
Shure: Let's hear your thoughts.
Lucia: 整体来说
Lucia: Overall.
Jake: 这个确实
Jake: This is indeed.
Jake: 模板他都写好了
Jake: The template is already written.
Shure:  我好像有
Shure: I think I have it.
Shure:  我试一下
Shure: Let me try it.
Jake: 还是问百度吧
Jake: Better ask Baidu.
Jake: 小度小度
Jake: Xiaodu, Xiaodu.
Shure:  抖音旗下还有个叫豆包的
Shure: There's another app called Doubao under Douyin.
Katrina: （歌词）那就是脆弱
Katrina: (lyrics) That is fragility.
Jake: 济仓节
Jake: Jicang Festival.
Jake: 喝谷雨茶
Jake: Drink Guyu tea.
Shure:  谷雨茶是啥
Shure: What's Guyu tea?
Shure:  我们点要不咱们点点奶茶吧今天
Shure: How about we order some milk tea today?
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Shure:  我靠好久没喝了
Shure: Damn, I haven't had this in a long time.
Jake: 二春茶
Jake: Erchun tea.
Jake: 一定得是上午采的茶
Jake: It has to be tea picked in the morning.
Shure:  记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that song?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 要跨着篮子到野外走来走去就叫走
Jake: You have to carry a basket and walk around in the wild, they call it "walking."
Jake: 走谷雨啊那我们就去玩狗去吧
Jake: Walking during Grain Rain, then let's go play with the dogs.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 要杀五毒
Jake: We need to kill the five poisons.
Jake: 要看到苍蝇得打这个
Jake: If you see a fly, you have to hit it.
Jake: 这是什么习俗吗
Jake: Is this some kind of custom?
Katrina: 不知道压花教程
Katrina: I don't know the flower pressing tutorial.
Shure:  看我这两天把我的号养成什么样了
Shure: Look what I've turned my account into these past two days.
Katrina: 养成非摇滚了
Katrina: Turned into non-rock.
Katrina: 真的是这样的吗
Katrina: Is it really like this?
Katrina: 我的步骤没有错耶
Katrina: I didn't make any mistakes in the steps.
Jake: 饺子你能吃几个呀
Jake: How many dumplings can you eat?
Katrina: 我我今天过去只能吃8个
Katrina: I, I can only eat 8 today.
Jake: 那吃8个你吃几个呀
Jake: If you eat 8, how many will you eat?
Jake: 我10个15个
Jake: I'll eat 10 or 15.
Shure:  十十个吧
Shure: Ten, ten.
Shure:  你就按10个
Shure: Just count 10.
Jake: 10个行
Jake: 10 is fine.
Jake: 按10个算
Jake: Let's count 10.
Jake: 再整点饼
Jake: And get some pancakes.
Jake: 还有那种什么叫叫香椿饼你知道吧
Jake: There's also something called Xiangchun pancakes, you know?
Shure:  不知道一种植物
Shure: I don't know, it's a type of plant.
Shure:  香椿啊香椿我知道
Shure: Xiangchun, oh, I know Xiangchun.
Shure:  应该什么
Shure: Should be something.
Shure:  你今天能吃几个饺子
Shure: How many dumplings can you eat today?
Shure:  100个哈哈哈
Shure: 100, hahaha.
Jake: 那你不吃
Jake: Then you won't eat.
Jake: 你不吃完不准走
Jake: You can't leave until you finish.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  没看过那个什么那个视频吗
Shure: Haven't you seen that video?
Shure:  那个
Shure: That one.
Shure:  你感觉今天数学能考多少分
Shure: How many points do you think you'll get in math today?
Shure:  80分然后啪下的卷59分呵呵
Shure: 80 points, then bam, 59 points, haha.
Katrina: 看过
Katrina: I've seen it.
Katrina: 买几个板来着
Katrina: How many boards did you buy?
Katrina: 步骤是一模一样的呀
Katrina: The steps are exactly the same.
Katrina: 结果是完全不一样的无所谓
Katrina: But the results are completely different, it doesn't matter.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Shure:  那谁呢我还能下棋吗
Shure: What about them? Can I still play chess?
Shure: 下棋吗
Shure: Play chess?
Katrina: 下什么棋啊
Katrina: What chess are you talking about?
Shure: 来下棋
Shure: Let's play chess.
Katrina: 下棋是那个游戏吗
Katrina: Is chess that game?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 前男友最爱
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend loved it.
Shure: 那我们就好好下一会
Shure: Then let's play for a while.
Katrina: 也许有人
Katrina: Maybe someone...
Katrina: 啊那是我的是不是
Katrina: Ah, is that mine?
Tasha: 不好意思
Tasha: Sorry.
Katrina: 没事没事
Katrina: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 我突然想起我好像到了一个
Katrina: I suddenly remembered I got a...
Katrina: 香薰
Katrina: Scented candle.
Katrina: 哼我倒没有那么精致
Katrina: Hmph, I'm not that refined.
Shure:  我以为你还有这手艺呢哈哈哈
Shure: I thought you had this skill, haha.
Katrina: 其实我是个很粗糙的人呐
Katrina: Actually, I'm quite rough.
Katrina: 太难啊
Katrina: It's too hard.
Shure:  你看看你看
Shure: Look at you, look.
Shure:  原来我私人iPad从来不会给我推
Shure: My private iPad never shows me...
Shure:  这种华语大流行你知道吗
Shure: This kind of popular Chinese music, you know?
Lucia: 这个应该也是到了好久了对
Lucia: This must have been here for a long time too, right?
Katrina: 是我的吗
Katrina: Is it mine?
Katrina: 哦你的
Katrina: Oh, it's yours.
Katrina: 拆快递拆的爽了
Katrina: Unpacking deliveries is so satisfying.
Katrina: （歌词）生命中有万世的可能
Katrina: (Lyrics) There are endless possibilities in life.
Katrina: （歌词）你就是我要遇见的特别的人
Katrina: (Lyrics) You are the special one I was meant to meet.
Alice: 剪刀嘞
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Katrina: 每个人都在找剪刀
Katrina: Everyone is looking for scissors.
Katrina: 你要不拿小刀去划
Katrina: Why don't you use a small knife to cut it?
Alice: 也没有小刀呀
Alice: There's no small knife either.
Katrina: 呃呃完了
Katrina: Uh oh, we're doomed.
Katrina: （歌词）让我们一起了解
Katrina: (Lyrics) Let's understand together.
Katrina: （歌词）多少天长地久
Katrina: (Lyrics) How long forever lasts.
Katrina: （歌词）有几回细水长流
Katrina: (Lyrics) How many times calm waters flow.
Katrina: （歌词）我们是对方特别的人
Katrina: (Lyrics) We are each other's special ones.
Katrina: （歌词）奋不顾身难舍难分
Katrina: (Lyrics) Recklessly devoted, hard to part.
Katrina: （歌词）不是一般人的认真
Katrina: (Lyrics) Not the usual kind of dedication.
Shure:  活过来了
Shure: Came back to life.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Shure:  活了
Shure: Alive.
Shure:  有啡子喝了
Shure: Got some coffee to drink.
Katrina: （歌词）生命中有万事的可能
Katrina: (Lyrics) There are endless possibilities in life.
Katrina: （歌词）就是我要遇见的特别的人
Katrina: (Lyrics) Just that special person I'm meant to meet.
Katrina: （歌词）有时候我们会更寂寞
Katrina: (Lyrics) Sometimes we feel even lonelier.
Katrina: （歌词）有时也会失败怕被淘汰
Katrina: (Lyrics) Sometimes we fail, afraid of being left out.
Katrina: （歌词）想去找一个明白而我曾经那么的等待
Katrina: (Lyrics) Wanting to find someone who understands, and I've been waiting so long.
Katrina: （歌词）原来你就是未来
Katrina: (Lyrics) Turns out you are the future.
Katrina: （歌词）总有你的存在
Katrina: (Lyrics) You are always there.
Katrina: （歌词）有你我的爱
Katrina: (Lyrics) With you, my love.
Katrina: （歌词）我们是对方特别的人
Katrina: (Lyrics) We are each other's special ones.
Katrina: （歌词）奋不顾身难舍难分
Katrina: (Lyrics) Recklessly devoted, hard to part.
Katrina: （歌词）不是一般人的认真
Katrina: (Lyrics) Not the usual kind of dedication.
Katrina: （歌词）若有暗示的可能
Katrina: (Lyrics) If there's a hint of possibility.
Katrina: 咱还有多剪刀吗
Katrina: Do we have more scissors?
Katrina: 是不是剪刀不够
Katrina: Are the scissors not enough?
Katrina: 他们拆快递都不够
Katrina: They don't have enough for opening packages.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thank you.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Shure:  类似小的茶包那种完了你直接丢
Shure: It's like a small tea bag, then you just throw it.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 这苦吗
Katrina: Is this bitter?
Shure:  拿着你泡他不苦
Shure: Hold it, brew it, it's not bitter.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 怎么播停了
Katrina: Why did the playback stop?
Shure:  可能看到你伤心了吧
Shure: Maybe it saw you were sad.
Katrina: 我没
Katrina: I'm not.
Katrina: 伤心我白天跟晚上是两个人
Katrina: Sad me during the day and night are two different people.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 噔噔噔这能不能直接压呀
Katrina: Can I just press this directly?
Katrina: 哎呀我真的能压出这种感觉吗
Katrina: Oh dear, can I really press it out like this?
Shure:  给你一个特别好看的纯爱
Shure: Here's a really beautiful pure love story for you.
Shure:  叫做黄昏时分牵着手
Shure: It's called "Holding Hands at Dusk".
Katrina: 哇这名字天好浪漫啊
Katrina: Wow, that name is so romantic.
Katrina: 哇这名字天好浪漫
Shure:  对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 讲的是那个
Shure: It's about that...
Shure:  是这个做音乐的
Shure: It's about making music.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: So, then...
Shure:  就是反正偶然机遇
Shure: By some chance...
Shure:  就被那种大唱片公司签了
Shure: He got signed by a big record company.
Shure:  然后就开始然后
Shure: And then he started...
Shure:  跟女主邂逅是他
Shure: He met the female lead.
Shure:  正好住到了这
Shure: He just happened to live here.
Shure:  我这概括能力好好差
Shure: My summarizing skills are really bad.
Katrina: 这怎么压呀
Katrina: How do you press this?
Shure:  各自都有各自的一个长处
Shure: Everyone has their own strengths.
Shure:  我现在有那个啥了
Shure: Now I have that...
Katrina: 你说这怎么压呀
Katrina: How do you press this?
Katrina: 拆开吧还是
Katrina: Should we open it up?
Katrina: 哎这好好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice.
Katrina: 直接这样一坨顶头上
Katrina: Just put this lump on top.
Shure:  顶头上我给你照两张呗
Shure: I'll take a couple of photos with it on top of your head.
Katrina: 我不要
Katrina: I don't want to.
Katrina: 但是他们说还可以烤他
Katrina: But they said you can bake it too.
Shure:  是能吃能炸其实
Shure: You can eat it or fry it, actually.
Katrina: 还能吃呢
Katrina: You can eat it?
Shure:  玉兰花炸了据说很好吃
Shure: Fried magnolia flowers are supposed to be delicious.
Katrina: 玉兰花我们学校也有玉兰花
Katrina: We have magnolia flowers at our school too.
Katrina: 你最后一天安排的活动是啥来着
Katrina: What was the activity you planned for the last day?
Katrina: 你最后一天安排的活动是什么
Shure:  水瓶吗
Shure: Was it the water bottle?
Katrina: 又在拉屎
Katrina: Pooping again.
Katrina: 这何尝不是一种心灵感应
Katrina: Isn't this a kind of telepathy?
Katrina: 我咋知道心灵感应
Katrina: How would I know about telepathy?
Katrina: 不想换
Katrina: I don't want to change.
Katrina: 啊我已经在楼下了
Katrina: Ah, I'm already downstairs.
Katrina: 怎么了我的睡衣怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong with my pajamas?
Katrina: 嗯想穿就穿
Katrina: Hmm, wear them if you want to.
Katrina: 不想不知道穿什么
Katrina: Don't know what to wear.
Katrina: t恤麻烦死了直接穿
Katrina: T-shirts are such a hassle, just wear this.
Katrina: 放的音响呀
Katrina: Put on the speakers.
Katrina: 看我的芍药花
Katrina: Look at my peonies.
Katrina: 做压花
Katrina: Making pressed flowers.
Katrina: 这个芍药可以拼好多
Katrina: These peonies can be arranged in so many ways.
Katrina: 呃还没有
Katrina: Uh, not yet.
Katrina: 吃了早饭
Katrina: Had breakfast.
Katrina: 中饭吃饺子还没到
Katrina: Lunch is dumplings, but it's not time yet.
Katrina: 呢我们的生活非常简单
Katrina: Our lives are very simple.
Katrina: 吃了睡睡了吃
Katrina: We eat, sleep, and repeat.
Katrina: 没啊前两天吃
Katrina: No, we had it a couple of days ago.
Katrina: 今天不想吃
Katrina: I don't feel like eating it today.
Katrina: 还压这种小花比较好看你看
Katrina: Pressing these little flowers looks nicer, see?
Katrina: 没干什么
Katrina: Didn't do much.
Katrina: 跳跳舞然后压压花
Katrina: Danced a bit and pressed some flowers.
Katrina: 然后把那个摘这个摘中间
Katrina: Then we picked this one and that one.
Katrina: 这也太小了这花瓣
Katrina: These petals are so small.
Katrina: 不用干活
Katrina: No need to work.
Katrina: 对啊带着就行
Katrina: Yeah, just wear them.
Katrina: 对啊就是我们在压花
Katrina: Yeah, we're pressing flowers.
Katrina: 然后他到时候他传给AI了
Katrina: Later, he will send it to AI.
Katrina: 他就问AI现在这个人在干什么
Katrina: He will ask AI what this person is doing now.
Katrina: 然后AI要试着理解我们在干什么
Katrina: Then AI will try to understand what we are doing.
Katrina: 就行了
Katrina: That's it.
Katrina: 就包括我昨天去商场夹了个娃娃
Katrina: Including when I went to the mall yesterday and grabbed a toy.
Katrina: 他们到时候就会问AI
Katrina: They will ask AI then.
Katrina: 这个娃娃是从哪里来的
Katrina: Where did this toy come from?
Katrina: 他要推推理整个时间过程
Katrina: It will have to deduce the whole timeline.
Katrina: 这就是他们要干的活
Katrina: That's what they need to do.
Katrina: 啊这个散了
Katrina: Ah, this one fell apart.
Katrina: 嗯我也没想到这么轻松
Katrina: Hmm, I didn't expect it to be this easy.
Katrina: 每天早上十十点半起床居然有
Katrina: Waking up at ten thirty in the morning every day, amazing.
Katrina: 我就是度假呀
Katrina: I'm on vacation.
Katrina: 我昨天还晚上我们弄烧烤啊什么的
Katrina: Yesterday evening we even had a barbecue or something.
Katrina: 是啊感觉提前过上了退休生活
Katrina: Yeah, it feels like I'm living the retired life early.
Katrina: 当时还以为是传销是不是
Katrina: At first, I thought it was a scam, right?
Katrina: 勇敢的人先享受世界
Katrina: The brave enjoy the world first.
Katrina: 今天不知道
Katrina: Today, I don't know.
Katrina: 这花瓣这白色
Katrina: These petals, this white one.
Katrina: 这好看吗这
Katrina: Does this look good?
Katrina: 星期一结束
Katrina: Monday's over.
Katrina: 嗯然后马上滚回学校做笔舍去了
Katrina: Hmm, then I'll quickly go back to school and finish my notes.
Katrina: 星期一结束
Katrina: Monday's over.
Katrina: 可能星期二或星期三走吧
Katrina: Maybe I'll leave on Tuesday or Wednesday.
Katrina: 可能会再住一晚上
Katrina: Might stay another night.
Katrina: 就跟上次我说一说话什么就
Katrina: Just like last time, we talked and stuff...
Katrina: 然后再一天白天就走
Katrina: Then leave during the day.
Katrina: 十多天吧
Katrina: About ten days, I guess.
Katrina: 真成北京土著了
Katrina: I've really become a local Beijinger.
Katrina: 每天还有小蛋糕吃
Katrina: Got little cakes every day.
Katrina: 因为有一个姐姐
Katrina: Because there's a lady.
Katrina: 她是开甜品店的
Katrina: She runs a dessert shop.
Katrina: 不是全网找的
Katrina: Not someone from the internet.
Katrina: 但她是研究生啊
Katrina: But she's a graduate student.
Katrina: 她是研究生
Katrina: She's a grad student.
Katrina: 但是她开的甜品店
Katrina: But she runs a dessert shop.
Katrina: 本来就是啊
Katrina: Well, yeah.
Katrina: 那文科研究生会比较轻松知道吧
Katrina: Liberal arts grad students have it easier, you know.
Katrina: 想干嘛干嘛
Katrina: They can do whatever they want.
Katrina: 他们现在就是也是研究生在上班
Katrina: They're grad students working now.
Katrina: 但是他们就可以出来
Katrina: But they can just take off.
Katrina: 就是消失一个星期
Katrina: Like disappear for a week.
Katrina: 导师都不管
Katrina: The mentor doesn't care at all.
Katrina: 然后像那个实验室的这个学姐
Katrina: And then there's this senior in the lab.
Katrina: 他就每天要打卡
Katrina: He has to check in every day.
Katrina: 他就来不了
Katrina: He can't make it.
Katrina: 理工科跟文科读研就这样
Katrina: That's how it is for STEM and humanities grad school.
Katrina: 区别很大
Katrina: There's a big difference.
Katrina: 是很忙啊
Katrina: It's really busy.
Katrina: 所以说大四要好好玩
Katrina: So, you should have fun in your senior year.
Katrina: 理工课都是这样
Katrina: STEM classes are like this.
Katrina: 学是学会了一点
Katrina: I learned a bit.
Katrina: 但我感觉我不太感兴趣
Katrina: But I don't find it very interesting.
Katrina: 因为这是我21号要做给别人的东西
Katrina: Because this is something I need to do for someone else on the 21st.
Katrina: 这是我的任务
Katrina: This is my task.
Katrina: 我说我这辈子没干过
Katrina: I said I've never done this in my life.
Katrina: 没干过这么细致的活
Katrina: Never done such detailed work.
Katrina: 因为故里也不要
Katrina: Because the old place didn't need it.
Katrina: 也不要有毛泽木的任务
Katrina: Didn't need such meticulous tasks.
Katrina: 就天天听听歌干干这些呗
Katrina: Just listen to music and do these things every day.
Katrina: 他们在外面拆快递
Katrina: They're unpacking parcels outside.
Katrina: 他们买的东西到了
Katrina: The stuff they bought arrived.
Katrina: 给你看他们在干嘛
Katrina: Let me show you what they're doing.
Katrina: 这我们的快递这么多
Katrina: Look at all our deliveries.
Katrina: 这是他买的那个甜品架啊
Katrina: This is the dessert stand he bought.
Katrina: 你买的甜品架吗
Katrina: Is this the dessert stand you bought?
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 咖啡色哎
Katrina: It's brown.
Katrina: 好好看
Katrina: Looks really nice.
Katrina: 21号邀请朋友来的时候他就做了
Katrina: On the 21st, when he invited friends over, he made it.
Katrina: 卡做了那个蛋糕什么
Katrina: He made a cake or something.
Katrina: 就放在这个里面
Katrina: He just put it in here.
Katrina: 哒哒哒昨天在这烤烤东西
Katrina: Yesterday, he was baking stuff here.
Katrina: 抖音就是
Katrina: TikTok is just...
Katrina: 差不多
Katrina: About the same.
Katrina: 没什么代沟啊
Katrina: There's no generation gap.
Katrina: 好玩的要命
Katrina: It's so much fun.
Katrina: 昨天去去公园散步溜了一圈
Katrina: Yesterday, we went for a walk in the park.
Katrina: 然后又去河马神仙买买肉买水果
Katrina: Then we went to Hema to buy meat and fruits.
Katrina: 买了然后晚上买了
Katrina: We bought them, and then we grilled meat at night.
Katrina: 晚上就烤肉吃
Katrina: We grilled and ate meat at night.
Katrina: 过上了老年生活
Katrina: Living the retired life.
Katrina: 就是把它剪下来
Katrina: Just cut it off.
Katrina: 然后把它平开
Katrina: Then spread it out.
Katrina: 然后这样放着就行呵呵
Katrina: Just put it like this, haha.
Lucia: 雨轩有找到剪刀吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, did you find the scissors?
Katrina: 剪刀是那个靖康给我的你用这个吧
Katrina: Jingkang gave me the scissors. You can use this.
Katrina: 但这个好拆快递吗
Katrina: But are these good for opening packages?
Lucia: 我也在想
Lucia: I'm also wondering.
Lucia: 这看起来就是剪花啊
Lucia: These look like they're for cutting flowers.
Alice: 来吧我来给你拆
Alice: Come on, I'll open it for you.
Lucia: 吧柔软一点的
Lucia: Maybe something softer.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's okay.
Shure:  第一步一步叫做分蒸
Shure: The first step is called "separate steaming."
Lucia: 没事没事拆快递其实我用我用这个东西拆也可以
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay. I can use this thing to open packages too.
Lucia: 我是在想
Lucia: I was just thinking...
Lucia: 如果我们要做一个纸箱鼓的话
Lucia: If we want to make a cardboard drum...
Lucia: 就需要用剪刀把这个剪掉
Lucia: We need to use scissors to cut this.
Katrina: 这个那那把红色的剪刀呢
Katrina: Where are the red scissors?
Lucia: 那我们肯定有剪刀的
Lucia: We definitely have scissors.
Lucia: 那个就要用那个
Lucia: We need to use those.
Lucia: 就是全是铁的那种剪刀
Lucia: The all-metal scissors.
Lucia: 那个我怕就是给他别用
Lucia: I'm afraid they'll be too sharp.
Lucia: 用劲太大剪劈了
Lucia: If we use too much force, they'll break.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Lucia: 现在戴着眼镜我可以拆这个快递了吧
Lucia: Now that I'm wearing glasses, I can open this package, right?
Lucia: 拆了管他可以反正没什么事
Lucia: I'll just open it, it doesn't matter anyway.
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Sure, go ahead.
Alice: 我找到了
Alice: I found it.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 那个是用来压花的吗
Lucia: Is that for pressing flowers?
Katrina: 对对
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以可以有个剪刀
Lucia: Okay, we have scissors.
Lucia: 然后我们好像没有铅笔
Lucia: But it seems like we don't have a pencil.
Lucia: 但实在不行白板笔也行
Lucia: If not, we can use a whiteboard marker.
Katrina: 我有那个就是黑笔你要吗
Katrina: I have a black pen, do you want it?
Lucia: 呃那个碳碳素笔那种吗
Lucia: Uh, like a carbon pen?
Katrina: 写字的
Katrina: For writing.
Katrina: 不是就普通的写字的黑
Katrina: No, just a regular black pen for writing.
Lucia: 可以也可以你要
Lucia: That works, do you need it?
Katrina: 你要干什么
Katrina: What do you need it for?
Lucia: 就是在纸板上画一下啊
Lucia: Just to draw something on the cardboard.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Got it.
Lucia: 我要那个什么
Lucia: I need that.
Katrina: 那我给你找找去
Katrina: I'll go find it for you.
Lucia: 没事没事不着急你可以先弄你的这个
Lucia: No rush, no rush, you can finish your thing first.
Katrina: 不着急
Katrina: No rush.
Katrina: 你有想好要做什么样的小狗吗
Katrina: Have you thought about what kind of puppy you want to make?
Lucia: 没想好因为
Lucia: Not yet, because...
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 因为我不知道咱们是想要一个
Lucia: Because I don't know if we want...
Lucia: 就是粗狗一点的还是
Lucia: Like a sturdy dog or...
Katrina: 就是看门狗
Katrina: Like a guard dog?
Katrina: 搞一个看门狗吧
Katrina: Let's make a guard dog.
Alice: 是一人一只吗
Alice: Is it one per person?
Lucia: 可以一起做
Lucia: We can make one together.
Lucia: 反正我们好多人
Lucia: Since there are many of us.
Katrina: 就是这个活动啥的
Katrina: It's like an activity.
Katrina: 就是感觉压花什么都是随便
Katrina: Pressing flowers and stuff is casual.
Katrina: 你想玩就玩
Katrina: Play if you want.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 对哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, haha.
Katrina: 我当时以为就是
Katrina: I thought...
Katrina: 必须每个人想一个游戏
Katrina: Everyone had to think of a game.
Katrina: 就是每个人都要参与那种
Katrina: So everyone has to participate in that kind of thing.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Yeah, me too.
Katrina: 后来发现后来发现特别佛系
Katrina: Later, I found out it was really laid-back.
Alice: 那我要做一只发疯的小狗
Alice: Then I want to be a crazy little dog.
Lucia: 就是就是其实那个狗很好做
Lucia: Actually, it's really easy to make that dog.
Lucia: 如果大家只是想潦草一点做的话
Lucia: If everyone just wants to do it sloppily,
Lucia: 就拿一个箱子
Lucia: just take a box.
Katrina: 做一个
Katrina: Make one.
Lucia: 但是长宽比例要合适一点
Lucia: But the proportions need to be a bit more accurate.
Katrina: 做一个余华老师
Katrina: Make a Mr. Yu Hua.
Lucia: 然后简单剪一下
Lucia: Then just cut it simply.
Lucia: 对就行了
Lucia: Yeah, that's it.
Lucia: 简单剪一下然后给他
Lucia: Just cut it simply and then
Lucia: 就你再拿另外一个那种
Lucia: you can take another one like that.
Lucia: 就是把那个纸然后画一个
Lucia: Just take that paper and draw a
Lucia: 小狗脑袋把它粘上
Lucia: little dog's head and stick it on.
Lucia: 我看还有很多就是那种的
Lucia: I see there are a lot like that.
Alice: 你的比例失调也没关系啊
Alice: It doesn't matter if your proportions are off.
Alice: 就有那种特别细长的那种细狗
Alice: There are those really long, thin dogs.
Katrina: 细狗
Katrina: Thin dogs.
Lucia: 就是就更加符合潦草小狗的形象
Lucia: Yeah, it fits the image of a sloppy little dog even more.
Jake: 但是这个优势就是这个
Jake: But the advantage is this.
Alice: 可以把眼镜先去掉
Alice: You can take off your glasses first.
Alice: 一会我要上厕所
Alice: I'll need to go to the bathroom later.
Katrina: 可以啊可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Alice: 这能播吗
Alice: Can this be broadcast?
Katrina: 可以哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, haha.
Alice: 哈哈能录吗
Alice: Haha, can it be recorded?
Lucia: 你可以先放桌子上
Lucia: You can put it on the table first.
Lucia: 然后出出来了再带
Lucia: Then bring it out later.
Lucia: 应该没事了
Lucia: It should be fine.
Lucia: 这你多来一个机位
Lucia: Just get another camera angle.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Katrina: OK嘿嘿
Katrina: OK, hehe.
Lucia: 这个也是昨天到的
Lucia: This one also arrived yesterday.
Lucia: 有谁的快有谁的
Lucia: Whose package is it?
Lucia: 京东快递是昨天到的吗
Lucia: Did the JD.com delivery arrive yesterday?
Katrina: 没有我没买京东
Katrina: No, I didn't buy from JD.
Katrina: 我都是淘宝
Katrina: I only use Taobao.
Katrina: 这什么东西啊
Katrina: What's this?
Lucia: 不知道因为这上面没写名字
Lucia: I don't know because it doesn't have a name on it.
Katrina: 易碎物品
Katrina: Fragile items.
Lucia: 然后我觉得应该也不是我的
Lucia: And I think it's not mine either.
Lucia: 因为我昨天应该就到了俩
Lucia: Because I should have received two yesterday.
Katrina: 两杨杨这个笑脸
Katrina: Two Jake smiley faces.
Katrina: 这谁写的
Katrina: Who wrote this?
Katrina: 应该不是我写的
Katrina: It shouldn't be me who wrote it.
Katrina: 杨靖康杨笑脸
Katrina: Jake Jingkang, Jake smiley face.
Lucia: 杨笑脸那可能是他自己写的
Lucia: Jake smiley face, maybe he wrote it himself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我写的
Lucia: Hahaha, I wrote it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我写的是
Lucia: I wrote it.
Lucia: 是我一直用来收快递的朱先生就是我写的
Lucia: It's the name I always use for receiving packages, Mr. Zhu, that's what I wrote.
Lucia: 朱先生哈哈
Lucia: Mr. Zhu, haha.
Lucia: 就是我的
Lucia: It's mine.
Lucia: 我微信不是叫那个啊朱先生
Lucia: My WeChat name isn't that, it's Mr. Zhu.
Katrina: 呀这应该这样
Katrina: Ah, it should be like this.
Katrina: 还这种小花好呀
Katrina: This little flower is nice.
Katrina: 大花就不知道怎么给他吃
Katrina: I don't know how to feed the big flower.
Tasha: 打歌服的话我还没有买
Tasha: I haven't bought the stage outfits yet.
Tasha: 我们要不要看看
Tasha: Should we take a look?
Katrina: 还是哦
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina: 你说衣服
Katrina: Are you talking about clothes?
Tasha: 嗯对怎么说呢
Tasha: Yeah, well, how should I put it...
Tasha: 我看了好多
Tasha: I've seen a lot.
Katrina: 跟那个后天
Katrina: And the day after tomorrow...
Tasha: 我在想每个人应该不太一样才行
Tasha: I think everyone should have different ones.
Katrina: 嗯哇
Katrina: Hmm, wow.
Katrina: 可以有新衣服了
Katrina: We can have new clothes.
Tasha: 就那种粉黑色的
Tasha: Like those pink and black ones.
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Sounds good.
Katrina: 那他们男生跳穿什么
Katrina: What about the boys, what do they wear?
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Lucia: 男生跳舞跟我们一样的
Lucia: The boys dance in the same outfit as us.
Tasha: 有你看这种的
Tasha: Look, like this.
Tasha: 这种的这个粉黑的
Tasha: This pink and black one.
Katrina: 这好好看
Katrina: This looks great.
Tasha: 粉黑的这个对吧
Tasha: The pink and black one, right?
Katrina: 这好好看
Katrina: This looks great.
Tasha: 然后还有这个也可以来个粉黑的
Tasha: And also, this one can be pink and black too.
Tasha: 然后这个也可以粉黑的
Tasha: Then this one can be pink and black too.
Katrina: 真给爆了
Katrina: Totally blew up.
Lucia: 我现在就是觉得还有这套他
Lucia: Right now, I just think there's still this set for him.
Tasha: 我现在就是觉得一套还有这套
Tasha: Right now, I just think there's still this set.
Tasha: 他他也是粉粉黑的那种
Tasha: He's also into pink and black.
Katrina: 嗯他给多少预算
Katrina: Hmm, what's the budget?
Tasha: 我尽量
Tasha: I'll try my best.
Tasha: 还可以吧
Tasha: Should be okay.
Tasha: 然后应该有三套了
Tasha: Then we should have three sets.
Tasha: 我在想哇这么重
Tasha: I'm thinking, wow, so heavy.
Tasha: 嗯对我找了好久才找到
Tasha: Yeah, I searched for a long time to find it.
Katrina: 那我再帮你找找吗
Katrina: Should I help you look?
Tasha: 我找了好久
Tasha: I looked for a long time.
Tasha: 就是好好多平台来回找才找着哎
Tasha: I searched through many platforms back and forth to find it.
Katrina: 哎咱一共是一二三四个女生加修硕
Katrina: So, we have a total of one, two, three, four girls plus Shure.
Katrina: 还有这个
Katrina: And this one.
Tasha: 我们这个也是这个
Tasha: This one too.
Tasha: 他可以团队
Tasha: He can be part of the team.
Katrina: 修硕穿裤子
Katrina: Shure wears pants.
Tasha: 这个这个然后一套两套
Tasha: This one, this one, then one set, two sets.
Katrina: 这个哈哈哈
Katrina: This one, haha.
Tasha: 一套两套
Tasha: One set, two sets.
Tasha: 还有这个
Tasha: And this one.
Tasha: 这个好五套五套六套就可以了
Tasha: This is good, five sets, five sets, six sets should be enough.
Katrina: 嗯可以
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 或者
Tasha: Or...
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Katrina: 嗯这一套也好看
Katrina: Hmm, this set looks good too.
Katrina: 嗯所以最后就是你要不直接发群
Katrina: Hmm, so in the end, why don't you just post it in the group?
Katrina: 然后大家挑
Katrina: And let everyone pick.
Tasha: 就6套吗
Tasha: Just six sets?
Tasha: 一共
Tasha: Total.
Lucia: 我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Alice: 就想要一套200块更均匀
Alice: Just want one set to be 200 bucks, more evenly.
Katrina: 一套200块的话6套1,200
Katrina: If one set is 200 bucks, six sets would be 1,200.
Tasha: 差不多1,000块钱左右
Tasha: About 1,000 bucks or so.
Tasha: 他会拨吗
Tasha: Will he approve?
Katrina: 你去问一下杨老板
Katrina: You go ask Jake.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 然后如果想要的话还得发顺丰才能够
Tasha: Then if we want it, we have to send it via SF Express to get it in time.
Tasha: 周日到啊
Tasha: Arriving on Sunday?
Katrina: 对确实对
Katrina: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 就是挑了好久才能找到一个一些
Tasha: It took quite a while to find some.
Katrina: 你先问他预算吧
Katrina: You should ask him about the budget first.
Katrina: 谁去问
Katrina: Who's going to ask?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 杨老板在哪
Katrina: Where's Jake?
Katrina: 粉丝团团长去问一下
Katrina: Let's have the fan club president ask.
Katrina: 我靠我有点害怕
Katrina: Oh man, I'm a bit scared.
Tasha: 哈哈我也有点害怕
Tasha: Haha, me too.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 就是感觉有点太高了
Tasha: It feels a bit too much.
Tasha: 但是但是每套都要很精致好看的话
Tasha: But if each set needs to be very delicate and beautiful...
Tasha:一百多也不贵
Tasha: Then over a hundred isn't too expensive.
Katrina: 嗯那是
Katrina: Yeah, that's true.
Katrina: 那就在群里问吧
Katrina: Let's just ask in the group.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 说杨老板那个衣服给多少钱报销
Katrina: Just ask how much reimbursement Jake is giving for the clothes.
Katrina: 啊那楼上没有牙膏了
Katrina: Oh, there's no toothpaste upstairs.
Katrina: 楼上没有牙膏了
Katrina: No toothpaste upstairs.
Katrina: 对没有牙膏
Katrina: Yeah, no toothpaste.
Katrina: 那就在群里跟他说一声
Katrina: Let's just tell him in the group.
Katrina: 唉就是现在找不到他人嘛
Katrina: Can't find him right now.
Katrina: 然后我们就在群里问一下他
Katrina: So we'll just ask in the group.
Tasha: 你问问杨老板
Tasha: Ask Jake.
Tasha: 打歌服六
Tasha: About the performance outfit.
Tasha: 个人1,000块钱
Tasha: Each person 1,000 yuan.
Tasha: 钱服装
Tasha: For the outfit.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 服装
Lucia: Outfit.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 打歌服是吗
Alice: For the performance outfit?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 切
Katrina: Tsk.
Katrina: 4女两男
Katrina: Four women and two men.
Katrina: 这是他们乐队的
Katrina: It's their band.
Alice: 这是
Alice: It is.
Lucia: 送给大家的
Lucia: It's a gift for everyone.
Alice: 这是鸟身上长了个柳树吗
Alice: Is that a tree growing on the bird?
Alice: 是吗
Alice: Really?
Alice: 接一下水
Alice: Could you get some water?
Alice: 你这看起来零零碎碎的
Alice: This looks all scattered.
Alice: 不太好拼的样子
Alice: Doesn't seem easy to piece together.
Katrina: 妹子西安的
Katrina: The girl is from Xi'an.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 都蛮高啊
Katrina: They're all quite tall.
Katrina: 嗯还得上班的
Katrina: Yeah, they still have to go to work.
Katrina: 研究生
Katrina: Graduate student.
Katrina: 这花这芍药好好闻
Katrina: These flowers, these peonies smell so good.
Katrina: 以后家里可以买点芍药
Katrina: We should buy some peonies for home in the future.
Katrina: 芍药开的又大
Katrina: Peonies bloom so big.
Jake: 乌鸦你觉得要动吗
Jake: Do you think the crow should move?
Jake: 这些箱子可能还得用吧
Jake: We might still need these boxes, right?
Lucia: 箱子一会我们要做的话就先留着吧
Lucia: If we're going to use the boxes later, let's keep them for now.
Jake: 我们都留着
Jake: We'll keep them all.
Jake: 行我们都留着吧
Jake: Alright, let's keep them all.
Lucia: 也不用都我看一眼
Lucia: We don't need to keep all of them, let me take a look.
Alice: 卢亚那个泡沫箱能帮我拆一下吗
Alice: Loya, can you help me dismantle that foam box?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 然后把那个蛋挞皮放到冰箱里冷冻
Alice: And then put that tart crust into the freezer.
Katrina: 撒不得VK了
Katrina: VK is too precious.
Alice: 阿姨那个没人可以进去
Alice: Auntie, no one can go in there.
Katrina: 太爽了有点
Katrina: It's a bit too enjoyable.
Alice: 你这个是你们的设计的LOGO吗
Alice: Is this your logo design?
Alice: 是这是鸟上长了个柳树的意思吗
Alice: Does it mean a bird with a willow tree?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Katrina: 你听他讲解一下呗
Katrina: Let him explain it to you.
Alice: 这不是一个鸟吗
Alice: Isn't this a bird?
Shure:  是鸟对
Shure: Yes, it's a bird.
Alice: 这是柳树吗
Alice: Is this a willow tree?
Shure:  这大概就是那种比较克苏鲁的感觉
Shure: It's more of a Cthulhu kind of feeling.
Shure:  你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure:  不是柳树
Shure: Not a willow tree.
Shure:  是那个内心是一个孩子那种感觉你懂吗
Shure: It's that kind of feeling where there's a child inside, you know?
Katrina: 哈哈哈直接把人解释懵了
Katrina: Haha, you completely confused her with that explanation.
Katrina: 那打歌服的预算是多少
Katrina: What's the budget for the stage costumes?
Jake: 一般是多少啊
Jake: What's the usual amount?
Jake: 我不太懂
Jake: I don't really know.
Katrina: 刚刚那个谁
Katrina: Just now, who was it...
Katrina: 微微看的是一百多一套
Katrina: Weiwei said it was over a hundred per set.
Jake: OK
Katrina: 一百多一套
Katrina: Each set is over a hundred
Katrina: 那六套的话那一百多
Katrina: So six sets would be over a hundred
Katrina: 一百多那就是一千以内
Katrina: Over a hundred, that means within a thousand
Jake: 就是
Jake: Exactly
Jake: 六六百 600多
Jake: Six, six hundred and something
Jake: 什么样的
Jake: What kind?
Jake: 600多
Jake: Over six hundred
Katrina: 他说挑的是粉色跟黑色系列
Katrina: He said he picked the pink and black series
Jake: 我我瞅瞅去
Jake: I'll go take a look
Katrina: 你瞅瞅哎
Katrina: You go take a look, yeah
Katrina: 他在这你给他瞅瞅
Katrina: He's here, show him
Jake: 来瞅一瞅你们的衣服
Jake: Come take a look at your clothes
Katrina: 哈哈呵呵
Katrina: Haha, hehe
Katrina: 我不知道
Katrina: I don't know
Katrina: 我在我在我在
Katrina: I'm here, I'm here, I'm here
Katrina: 那些天天天天
Katrina: Those everyday, everyday, everyday
Katrina: 一件t恤加裤子一双图案天天过就
Katrina: A T-shirt, pants, and a pair of shoes every day
Alice: 这怎么是一整个
Alice: How is this a whole...
Katrina: 是我我我
Katrina: It's me, me, me
Katrina: 嗯每天都有一件
Katrina: Yeah, there's one every day
Katrina: T恤啊
Katrina: A T-shirt
Katrina: 你用的裤子
Katrina: And the pants you use
Katrina: 黑色衣都黑色衣
Katrina: All black clothes, all black clothes
Jake: 都好看
Jake: All look good
Jake: 想想啊
Jake: Think about it
Lucia: 这是个完整的
Lucia: This is a complete set
Lucia: 这是啥情况
Lucia: What's the situation here?
Alice: 这吧我可以看一下这个吗
Alice: Can I take a look at this?
Katrina: 可以这个是我觉得
Katrina: Sure, I think this one
Katrina: 哈哈哈这坨里面长了两个
Katrina: Haha, there are two inside this lump
Katrina: 还能这个
Katrina: And also this one
Katrina: 然后还有就是那个
Katrina: And then there's that one
Katrina: 可以弄在那个亚克力板里面
Katrina: You can put it in the acrylic board
Katrina: 应该会挺好看
Katrina: It should look quite nice
Katrina: 我在想要不要压一点
Katrina: I'm thinking of pressing it
Katrina: 你要压吗
Katrina: Do you want to press it?
Katrina: 现在还有
Katrina: There's still some left
Katrina: 你可以把你那个盛开的就压一下
Katrina: You can press the one that's blooming
Katrina: 随便弄两个就行
Katrina: Just press a couple, it's fine
Katrina: 我这有有几个板
Katrina: I have a few boards here.
Katrina: 其实特简单
Katrina: Actually, it's really simple.
Katrina: 就是把它一层层叠起来然后铺在上面
Katrina: You just stack them layer by layer and then lay them on top.
Katrina: 然后把它绑住就可以
Katrina: Then tie them up and that's it.
Alice: 它的原理是
Alice: The principle is...
Katrina: 就是干燥板
Katrina: It's just drying boards.
Alice: 就是让这些容易吸水的材质
Alice: It's to let these absorbent materials...
Alice: 把它的水分吸干
Alice: Absorb the moisture completely.
Jake: 嗯这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Hmm, is there any place that rents these?
Katrina: 嗯它就是
Katrina: Hmm, it's just that...
Tasha: 租的不知道
Tasha: Not sure about renting.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Sigh.
Jake: 或者这玩意这玩意
Jake: Or maybe this thing... this thing...
Tasha: 干掉
Tasha: Dry it out.
Tasha: 什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean?
Alice: 超预算了
Alice: Over budget.
Alice: 那要不统一买50块钱一套的
Alice: How about we all buy a set for 50 bucks each?
Jake: 不是就看你问问他
Jake: No, just check with him.
Jake: 你问问他
Jake: Ask him.
Katrina: 可以买便宜点的吗
Katrina: Can we buy something cheaper?
Katrina: 穿一次那种
Katrina: Like those one-time use ones.
Jake: 便宜点或者你看能不能退掉
Jake: Cheaper ones or see if you can return it.
Jake: 二手还是能不能借租
Jake: Second-hand or rent it.
Katrina: 对啊 21号 不是
Katrina: Yeah, the 21st. No...
Alice: 或者搜一下附近有没有什么拍照的
Alice: Or maybe search if there's a photo studio nearby.
Alice: 什么写真馆的
Alice: Like a portrait studio.
Alice: 他们那种礼服
Alice: They might have those outfits.
Jake: 这种也行
Jake: That works too.
Katrina: 就21号不是邀请朋友来吗
Katrina: So, on the 21st, we're inviting friends over, right?
Katrina: 就那个世界地球日
Katrina: It's Earth Day.
Katrina: 然后我们要做小蛋糕
Katrina: And we're making small cakes.
Katrina: 然后做的这些每个人要想一个活动
Katrina: And everyone has to come up with an activity.
Katrina: 我不是想的是压花吗
Katrina: I thought about doing pressed flowers.
Katrina: 然后就可以送给别人
Katrina: And then we can give them to others.
Katrina: 这种
Katrina: Like this.
Katrina: 压的跟坨屎一样你看
Katrina: It looks like a pile of crap, look.
Katrina: 怎么跟网上的那个结果不一样啊
Katrina: Why doesn't it look like the ones online?
Katrina: 怎么人家压出来是那一大片一大片
Katrina: How come theirs are in nice big pieces?
Katrina: 我压出来这
Katrina: And mine looks like this?
Katrina: 没办法这个必须要
Katrina: There's no way, we have to do this.
Katrina: 做点手工活
Katrina: Let's do some crafts.
Katrina: 我们要环保
Katrina: We need to be eco-friendly.
Katrina: 我知道啊
Katrina: I know.
Katrina: 所以这个还算比较简单
Katrina: So this is actually quite simple.
Katrina: 他其实只要把花瓣铺上面
Katrina: He just needs to lay the petals on top.
Katrina: 一定是哪个环节出了问题
Katrina: There must be something wrong with a step.
Katrina: 我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina: 压重大花瓣应该就不会有什么问题
Katrina: Pressing down the big petals should be fine.
Alice: 为什么我觉得这个屋子比别的要热
Alice: Why do I feel like this room is hotter than others?
Alice: 是因为电脑多吗
Alice: Is it because there are more computers?
Katrina: 每天是过得很快
Katrina: Every day goes by so fast.
Katrina: 10点半才开始
Katrina: We only start at 10:30.
Katrina: 讲讲话
Katrina: Let's chat.
Katrina: 主要有人唠嗑呀
Katrina: Mainly because someone is always chatting.
Tasha: 哦还真有租的
Tasha: Oh, there really are rentals.
Katrina: 附近有这种店然后直接去也行
Katrina: There are shops nearby, we can just go directly.
Tasha: 45一套那为什么不买一套呢
Tasha: 45 for a set, then why not buy a set?
Tasha: 买一套不在40吗
Tasha: Isn't it only 40 to buy a set?
Katrina: 唯一的压力就是呃
Katrina: The only pressure is, uh...
Katrina: 我们每次休息的时候
Katrina: Every time we take a break,
Katrina: 我要去忙一会工作
Katrina: I have to work for a bit.
Katrina: 就没了
Katrina: That's all.
Katrina: 我我每天我每天
Katrina: I, I every day, every day...
Katrina: 就是那个工作室
Katrina: It's just the studio.
Katrina: 还有那个叫叫叫必胜嘛
Katrina: And that place, called, called, called Bison.
Katrina: 然后每天就倒头就睡
Katrina: And then I just fall asleep every day.
Katrina: 电脑放旁边
Katrina: Computer beside me.
Katrina: 然后就倒头就睡
Katrina: Then I just fall asleep.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 嗯杜卓芸因太忙了
Katrina: Hmm, Du Zhuoyun is too busy.
Katrina: 我在想找个别人
Katrina: I'm thinking of finding someone else.
Katrina: 他的重心在学习和实验
Katrina: His focus is on studying and experiments.
Katrina: 还有摄影
Katrina: And photography.
Katrina: 蝴蝶我也想听蝴蝶
Katrina: Butterfly, I also want to listen to Butterfly.
Katrina: 再压一层
Katrina: Press another layer.
Katrina: 那肯定是我还没有决定
Katrina: I haven't decided yet.
Katrina: 好陶喆
Katrina: Okay, Tao Zhe.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 桌子怎么长成这样
Jake: How did the table get like this?
Katrina: 这是收纳箱哎
Katrina: This is a storage box!
Lucia: 不是他拼起来
Lucia: No, he assembled it.
Katrina: 我到时候买这些装饰房间东西
Katrina: I'll buy these decorations for my room later.
Katrina: 我就不带回去
Katrina: I won't take them back.
Katrina: 我直接给你寄回家了
Katrina: I'll just have them shipped directly to my home.
Alice: 这是一个不太小的工作量耶
Alice: That's quite a bit of work.
Katrina: 就都买绿色系的
Katrina: Just buy everything in green.
Katrina: 到时候直接放我房间就行
Katrina: Then just put them in my room.
Katrina: 买那种香薰
Katrina: Buy those scented diffusers.
Katrina: 还有地毯
Katrina: And rugs.
Katrina: 还有挂画
Katrina: And wall art.
Katrina: 还有娃娃
Katrina: And stuffed animals.
Lucia: 就是他带一个抽屉
Lucia: He brought a drawer.
Lucia: 所以他会边上要
Lucia: So, he needs the side...
Katrina: 森林主题绿色
Katrina: Forest-themed green.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina: 去二楼吃饺子吗
Katrina: Are we eating dumplings on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼吃饺子
Jake: Dumplings on the second floor.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Tasha: 到了吗
Tasha: Are we there yet?
Jake: 对冰箱也可以
Jake: Yeah, the fridge will do too.
Alice: 我们吃饭的时候需要录吗
Alice: Do we need to record while we're eating?
Jake: 呃吃饭录着吧
Jake: Uh, let's record while eating.
Katrina: 这东西这怎么压呀这这这
Katrina: How do you press this thing down?
Katrina: 纯立体啊
Katrina: It's completely three-dimensional.
Jake: 空心桌子是吧
Jake: It's a hollow table, right?
Lucia: 就是他是一个
Lucia: It's just...
Katrina: 看收纳
Katrina: Look at the storage.
Lucia: 那最后是一个这样的一个小东西
Lucia: So, in the end, it's this little thing.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就有点像小床头柜
Lucia: It's kind of like a small bedside table.
Alice: 让我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Jake: 嗯那这个就合理了起来
Jake: Mm, that makes sense now.
Katrina: 是
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 突然makesense
Jake: Suddenly, it makes sense.
Tasha: 那培养皿得好等会
Tasha: What about the petri dish?
Tasha: 培养皿买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the petri dish?
Tasha: 在哪
Tasha: Where is it?
Tasha: 还不种
Tasha: Aren't we planting?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 种
Jake: Seed
Jake: 还有别的喝吗
Jake: Got any other drinks?
Katrina: 浴巾康乃馨
Katrina: Towel and carnations
Katrina: 这个这有个快递是那个杨笑脸
Katrina: There's a package here for Yang Smile
Katrina: 谁的
Katrina: Whose is it?
Katrina: 我给你我直接写的杨靖康
Katrina: I wrote it as Yang Jingkang for you
Katrina: 那应该不是我买的杨笑脸
Katrina: That shouldn't be something I bought, Yang Smile
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 杨笑脸interesting
Jake: Yang Smile, interesting
Katrina: 是你买的吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Jake: 我不知道我看一下
Jake: I don't know, let me check
Jake: 这什么这什么呀
Jake: What is this, what is this?
Katrina: 这什么呀
Katrina: What is this?
Jake: 蝴蝶风铃我的
Jake: Butterfly wind chime, it's mine
Katrina: 我的哈哈哈
Katrina: It's mine, hahaha
Katrina: 快看看啊
Katrina: Quick, take a look
Katrina: 这是我材料包
Katrina: This is my material kit
Katrina: 今天又做手工了
Katrina: Making crafts again today
Katrina: 昨天化妆今天不想化妆
Katrina: Didn't want to put on makeup today after doing it yesterday
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 这我买的
Katrina: I bought this
Katrina: 蝴蝶风铃
Katrina: Butterfly wind chime
Katrina: （歌词）每次一见到你相遇那天起
Katrina: (Lyrics) Every time I see you since the day we met
Katrina: （歌词）就像一只蝴蝶
Katrina: (Lyrics) It's like a butterfly
Katrina: 你在追什么剧啊
Katrina: What show are you watching?
Jake: 这是货币是吧
Jake: This is currency, right?
Jake: 中央银行
Jake: Central bank
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah
Katrina: 呵呵呵 150个差不多吧
Katrina: Haha, about 150 should be enough
Jake: 可以挺好大银行
Jake: That's good, big bank
Katrina: 货币
Katrina: Currency
Katrina: （歌词）答应我自己现在我能坦然面对自己
Katrina: (Lyrics) Promise me, I can face myself calmly now
Katrina: （歌词）只要珍惜
Katrina: (Lyrics) As long as I cherish
Katrina: （歌词）我会永远爱你
Katrina: (Lyrics) I will love you forever
Lucia: 哦我明白了这好像也不是那么难搞
Lucia: Oh, I get it now. This isn't that hard to handle
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe
Katrina: AI学习中
Katrina: AI is learning
Jake: 呵呵挺好
Jake: Haha, that's good
Jake: 你这说明书对应的挺好呵呵呵
Jake: Your manual matches well, haha
Lucia: 我才是AI
Lucia: I am the AI
Tasha: 通州区演出服装租赁
Tasha: Tongzhou District costume rental
Jake: 这个好甚至我们可以去挑啊
Jake: This is good, we could even go pick some out
Jake: 如果不远的话
Jake: If it's not far
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Jake: 不远的话下午我们打个车去挑衣服
Jake: If it's not far, we can take a cab this afternoon to pick out clothes
Jake: 都可以
Jake: It's all good
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice: 为什么不能打个车去买衣服
Alice: Why can't we take a cab to buy clothes
Alice: 哈哈哈没关系我只是随便说说
Alice: Hahaha, it's okay, I'm just kidding
Jake: 到到时候算算
Jake: We'll see then
Jake: 算一算看看这打车费加上这多少钱
Jake: We'll see how much the cab fare adds up to
Jake: 打折费应该到不了1,000
Jake: The discounted fare shouldn't be over 1,000
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 财务人员的一项工作
Lucia: One of the tasks of a finance person